kid rock was interviewed by tucker
carlson a few days ago and he said
something about cancel culture that i
actually thought was pretty important so
i want to play that for you listen
why haven't you been canceled like
people aren't allowed to say what they
think you are i am uncancelable why is
that
because i don't give up
and i'm not in bed with any big
corporate things at the end of the day
there's nobody i'm beholden to no record
companies no corporate interests no
nothing and you can't cancel me
i love it when they try i'm like yeah so
why aren't there more artists like that
because they're in bed with record
companies and you know corporate deals
and structures at every level and
you know it's um and if someone finds a
way to get me a little bit here and
there i'll find another way around it
you never see artists talk like that
they seem very easy to intimidate
at what point did you realize like
you're just not gonna be intimidated
day one really i think i crawled out of
the womb with both middle fingers in the
air
so he he's he's right that there are
it's an important point
that there are two ways
to get canceled
and it's really there's really only two
there are only two ways for it to happen
um two kind of categories it's just
unfortunately a great many people fall
into one of these categories or both
so either
in order to be canceled you have to be
beholden to corporate interests
um as a great many people are i mean if
you if you work for a big giant
corporation then in that way you're
beholden to them because you work for
them um
through no fault of your own i mean you
have to have a job but so that that's
one way if you're kind of at the mercy
of
giant corporations then that's one way
to get canceled
the other way is if you if you care what
the mob thinks about you
and that's why we see people who
wouldn't seem to really be beholden to
anyone there's no reason why they need
to be beholden
rich and famous people got all the money
in the world and
even if they get cancelled by
corporations they're not really canceled
they're still going to be rich they're
still going to be famous they could go
out on their own and do their own thing
but they still apologize and crumble and
everything because
although they're not really beholding
the corporate interests or maybe they
are a little bit the bigger issue is
that they care what the mob thinks
so either you care what the mob things
or you're beholding the corporate
interest
um or or both
you know and for a lot of people it's
both especially a lot of celebrities and
so on the answer is both there
so if you want to be uncancelable that's
that's the way to do it now
you know unfortunately
lots of people are not in the spot that
kid rock is in
where you could be
wealthy and all of that and you know you
don't really you're not you don't need
to go to any corporation or anyone
looking for a job you can kind of do
your own thing so not everyone's in that
spot but at least one thing that
everybody can adopt
um
is the second part
which gives you a
some cover anyway in cancel culture
which is to stop caring what the mob
thinks to begin with
a lot of the cancellations that happen
it's really a it's a it's a
self-cancellation the mob
gives the gun to the canceled person and
just convinces them to pull the trigger
against themselves metaphorically
and you know eventually we get the point
we can't with canceled culture where
it's not so metaphorical
um and that that happens quite often
so you get you got to get to a point
where it just doesn't mean anything to
you and you realize
that first of all all these labels that
are thrown at you anytime you cancel
it's always going to be under the guise
of
racism sexism transphobia whatever
um
and you get to the point where you
realize that these labels don't mean
anything at all
i mean after all they're being thrown at
you by people who as we saw even on the
supreme court
or who want to be the supreme court
can't can't define a word like woman so
they certainly
in an abstract kind of concept like
transphobia that doesn't mean anything
now that really doesn't mean anything
who cares if you're called that
and most of the people in the mob who
are coming after you and attacking you
and insulting you
they don't actually care that much you
don't mean anything to them this is all
a game to them this is a power game
power struggle they want to impose their
will on you
not much different from the bully in the
playground you know it's a playground
bully mentality
but
nationwide formed into a mob
ideologically driven
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated